bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat c'est un débat dont
l'issue aura longtemps été incertaine
finalement les sénateurs ont adopté dans
la nuit de vendredi à samedi à 2h du
matin le projet de loi de réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
sans surprise les sénateurs communistes
ont voté contre ce texte
il l'avait d'ailleurs annoncé dès le
début des débats c'est donc grâce aux
voix des sénateurs centristes que ce
projet de loi a pu être adoptées pour
valérie létard sénatrice udi uc du nord
ce texte est loin d'être parfait mais il
est bien meilleur que celui qui nous est
parvenu de l'assemblée nationale pour
geneviève fioraso la ministre en charge
de ce projet de loi c'est l'intérêt
général qui a primé
je vous rappelle que l'objectif
ambitieux de ce projet de loi est de
porter et de diplômés à 50% d'une
génération afin d'élever son niveau de
qualification alors cet après midi
retour sur les explications de vote de
ce texte bon après midi à tous je vais
donc monsieur alfonsi pour explication
de vote madame état après madame la
présidente madame le ministre
chers collègues que les tiennes objectif
de ce texte
son ambition donner un nouveau souffle à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche par la définition d'une
stratégie nationale qui doit être source
de cohérence de coordination et
d'efficacité des politiques menées par
les différents acteurs
à ce titre on peut que saluer la volonté
du retour de l'état stratège d'ing
évidemment nous nous réjouissons d'avoir
honte et de l'état de favoriser la
valorisation de la recherche
cependant nous craignons que la mesure
proposée soit insuffisante alors que la
recherche technologique ne représente
que 10%
de notre dépense intérieure de recherche
aujourd'hui chacun s'accorde à dire que
la situation des universités
particulièrement grave pour le quart
d'entre elles et l'adoption de ce texte
sans les moyens financiers
correspondants à vous tirer à la mise en
oeuvre d'une loi lru déguisé la
sanctuarisation du budget de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche au sein du budget de l'étang
est rassurante mais elle ne saurait être
suffisante il faut aller plus loin il
faudra de nouvelles assurances
comment les universités répondre était
en effet aux attentes de la société
si leur autonomie allait se résumer à
réduire les dépenses qui permet de
dispenser des cours de qualité dans des
conditions d'accueil digne de ce nom
le taux d'échec demeure élevé à
l'université que nous nous éloignons
l'objectif de lisbonne qui vise à ce que
50 % d'une classe d'âge soit titulaire
d'un diplôme d'enseignement supérieur
mais au delà de quantité cden la qualité
de l'excellence du court chercher sa
clarification du paysage des formations
grâce à la procédure d'accréditation la
spécialisation progressive en 10 ans et
la création de passerelles entre
formations devraient participer à
l'amélioration de la réussite des
étudiants de même en matière
d'orientation la mise en place d'un
pourcentage minimum de bacheliers
technologiques et professionnels au sein
des 8es dsds peut contribuer à la
réussite de ses élèves
notre plus grande déception toutefois
conscient la gouvernance des universités
et le regrettons fortement que
l'amendement que nous avions présenté à
la tique 25 et qui a été adopté par le
sénat soit tombé du fait de la
suppression de cet article
il avait pour vertu de permettre à la
démocratisation de la gouvernance sans
ouvrir la porte au bicéphalisme et aux
risques de conflit paralysant les sp
venions ainsi que la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer le nouveau
texte tient compte de ces préoccupations
fondamentales pour les universités enfin
ne pas envenimer les relations entre les
conseils d'administration le conseil
académique nous y serons très attentifs
ne convient pas d'ajouter en effet des
blocages institutionnels aux problèmes
en matière de gestion des clients ce
qu'ils connaissent et universités pour
conclure il convient de saluer
l'engagement et la volonté du
gouvernement avec de réformes encore
inachevé mais qui se complètent celles
qui visent à refonder l'école de la
république et celle qui réforment
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
aussi malgré des réserves certaine mais
aussi quelques regrets de ne pas avoir
vu davantage nos amendements adoptés le
groupe rdse approuvera dans sa grande
majorité le texte ici ce soit les
travaux de la haute assemblée je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
valérie létard
la présidente madame la ministre chers
collègues nous arrivons au bout de
l'examen d'un texte passionnant et
animer tout en étant serein et
passionnant à de nombreux titres d'abord
comme je le rappelais par le le fond des
sujets traités leur importance pour
l'avenir des universités et de la
recherche française par la nature des
débats et bien sûr par les
rebondissements nous avons eu sur ce
projet de loi un tous ces
rebondissements que nous avons connues
collectivement avant de commenter le
texte qui résulte de nos discussions je
souhaiterais salué la qualité des
échanges qui ont eu lieu entre tous les
groupes du sénat assise ainsi qu avec
madame la ministre
et madame le rapporteur nos débats ont
été constructifs
chacun a pu défendre ses arguments faire
adopter un certain nombre d'amendements
tout cela sans dogmatisme et sans excès
je tiens à remercier tout
particulièrement la commission des
affaires culturelles sa rapporteure avec
qui en tant que rapporteur de la
commission des affaires économiques
nous avons pu préparer ce texte est
avancé en cohérence je remercie aussi
bien sûr la commission des affaires
économiques qui nous a soutenus en amont
de cette commission sur un certain
nombre d'amendements
ce n'était pas évident au début de ce
débat et le travail que nous avons mené
tout au long de ces trois jours nous a
permis et bien en fin de compte de
donner satisfaction à une certaine
partie effectivement de ces amendements
de la commission des affaires et comme
le font même du texte
je note de nombreuses évolutions qui
vont dans un sens qui me satisfait qui
satisfait mon groupe 6 le travail en
commissions les biens ils n'avaient pas
abouti à une ouverture suffisante vers
nos propositions
maintenant voilà c'est recevable je
tiens à rappeler à cet instant
l'adoption d'amendements qui tenait à
coeur au groupe uc udi d'abord le vote
de notre proposition permettant la
création d'un véritable statut pour les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
privé à but non lucratif celui ci est
une très grande satisfaction
elle va permettre non seulement une plus
grande transparence et une clarification
de la situation de ces états
glissement associatif mais aussi la
sécurisation des diplômes pour les 77
mille étudiants qui les fréquentent
en second lieu les propositions de mon
collègue jean léonce dupont sur la
publication des statistiques du taux
d'intégration professionnelle des
étudiants ainsi que de véritables
chiffres des inscriptions dans les
universités qui permettront de mieux
évaluer la qualité et l'intérêt des
formations proposées ensuite l'adoption
d'un amendement notre collègue hervé
maurey visant à régionaliser les
épreuves classantes des études de
médecine en ouvrant dans chaque région
un quota de postes qui soit en
adéquation avec les particularités des
régions de la région en terme de
démographie médicale qui permettra de
commencer à lutter contre les déserts
médicaux
enfin sur la valorisation des résultats
de la recherche
je me réjouis des amendements adoptés à
l'article 55 qui devrait permettre une
meilleure exploitation des inventions en
particulier vers les pme pmi et pays
sans pour autant et bien avoir un
dispositif qui ne sécurise pas la
possibilité d'aller au maximum de ce
qu'on peut faire en matière de
valorisation des brevets français alors
tout ceci était essentielle pour la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
effectivement la garantie qu'à donner
madame la ministre sur le brevet unifiée
européen
quant à son examen et à sa présentation
devant le parlement avant la fin de
l'année est aussi quelque chose qui est
important l'article 38 nous l'avons vu à
intégrer des propositions d'amendements
des commissions et a satisfait plusieurs
de nos groupes aujourd'hui et je crois
que là aussi cela a contribué à faire
évoluer notre position au final chers
collègues nous sommes donc face à un
texte qui est loin d'être parfait malgré
tout mais qui est largement meilleur que
celui qui nous est arrivé de l'assemblée
nationale les députés centristes nos
collègues députés s'y était d'ailleurs
opposé les progrès accomplis ont
convaincu le groupe udc de réviser son
jugement sur le projet de loi
en outre alors que nous sommes sur un
examen en procédure accélérée
ce que nous regrettons évidemment cette
lecture est la seule occasion pour le
sénat de présenter un texte qui lui
appartient avec
des spécificités et des ajouts qui
seront discutés en cmp sans cela est une
fois de plus
j'allais dire la voix du sénat ne
porterait pas ainsi mes collègues
centristes et moi même souhaitons qu'un
texte sorte de notre assemblée
nous serons donc extrêmement vigilants
et combatifs lors de la cmp pour que les
avancées que j'ai cités soit maintenue
et que les batailles que nous avons mené
ces derniers jours se transforme en
véritable victoire
en tout cas c'est pour ces raisons que
le vote que vont donner les sénateurs du
groupe uc udi sera partagé entre
l'abstention et le soutien au projet de
loi
pour ma part je le voterai favorablement
parce que comme je viens de le dire de
le dire je souhaite que ce texte il
puisse faire en sorte que le sénat
puisse continuer à faire progresser un
texte de façon utile et dans l'intérêt
général
merci madame létard la parole est à mme
lam gonthier maurin
oui madame la présidente madame à
ministre mes chers collègues je
vais sans surprise à l'issue de nos
travaux confirmer notre vote contre ce
projet de loi la discussion et les
modifications opérées au sénat n'ont pas
été de notre de nature à changer
profondément le texte et par voie de
conséquence le vote que nous sommes
amenés à faire la suppression puis la
réécriture de l'article 38 suite à une
demande de deuxième délibération par le
gouvernement on n'a pas à apaiser nos
inquiétudes sur les nouvelles modalités
de regroupements territoriaux comme je
les ai indiqué nous a tendu en effet des
signes de rupture claire avec les
politiques précédemment menées et nous
ne les trouvons pas dans ce texte les
responsabilités et compétences élargies
sont maintenus il y a également le
maintien de la logique d'évaluation mise
en oeuvre par la rs même si sa
dénomination sa dénomination n'a été
changé il n'y a pas de retour sur la nr
ni d'encadrement de ces appels à projets
qui favorisent l'emploi précaire et
évidemment les mesures en faveur de la
résorption de la précarité sont
extrêmement faible car il n'y a pas de
programmation de moyens et d'emploi dans
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
au stade où nous nous parlons nous
déplorons par ailleurs nous l'avons
rappelée à longueur du texte
la focalisation excessive des objectifs
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche sur des visées utilitariste en
vue de retombées économique et
d'employabilité donc encore une fois
nous confirmons notre vote contre si
madame la présidente madame blue
madame la présidente madame la ministre
la présidente de commission madame les
rapporteurs chers collègues trois points
des remerciements qui ne sont pas que de
forme un certain nombre de regrets et
ensuite le sens du vote le remerciement
je voulais commencer parce que peut-être
parfois on oublie pas remercié la
présidente de séance sans laquelle je
pense notre discussion et ça avait déjà
été le la même chose au moment du vote
de la loi peillon je pense sans laquelle
là on va dire le la sérénité n'aurait
peut-être pas été aussi grande pour nous
permettre d'avancer à une heure tardive
mais encore raisonnable ensuite voilà
remercier tout ceux et toutes celles qui
ont fait en sorte qu'on ait pu
travailler dans de bonnes conditions y
compris y compris les toutes les
personnes de cette maison est donc
collaborateurs aussi qu'on a malmené
avec 10 aurait des horaires de travail
peut-être pas très correct non plus
voilà voilà
alors ensuite soyons soyons très clairs
on va on va pas on va pas faire la liste
de tous les regrets mais le premier
regret si vous voulez ça a été dit par
notre collègue tient au fait que
l'urgence était mise en oeuvre sur ce
texte
nous pensons que l'urgence dans ce cas
était gage de précipitations et de
travail bâclé et donc plus un certain
nombre de pas entendu de malentendus et
de désaccord très profond je pense qu'il
faut que l'on retienne que ça n'était
pas la bonne méthode
ensuite des regrets parce qu'évidemment
il n'y a pas la suppression de la nerfs
ça a été évoqué par certains la course
la course au projet ne s'arrêtera pas ça
c'est très clair je ne parle même pas du
fait que ça n'est pas une loi de
programmation puisque en fait on a déjà
vu que s'il y avait des postes et de la
sécurisation de l'emploi qui ont été
annoncées les cinq fois mille postes bon
on les attend il faudra vérifier la
sécurisation dans le cadre des
protocoles existants même chose il
faudra vraiment vérifier que ça se fait
bien donc si vous voulez on est vraiment
très loin du grand soir est très loin
d'une loi qui aurait été
on va dire une rupture significative par
rapport à ce qu'on attendait un certain
nombre d'inquiétudes que nous avions ne
se sont pas présentés donc on va on
restera vigilant vous connaissez notre
inquiétude notamment par rapport à
toutes les questions de brevetabilité du
vivant
il ya quand même eu des points
clairement je dirais plutôt positif on
avait un texte qui pour nous était très
très mauvais hélas après un travail
collectif on a un texte qui nous semble
moins mauvais qui tient en compte les
contradictions très profondes qui ont
été posées qui posent des questions et
on veut que je pense qu'on veut montrer
que le travail au sénat un sens que le
travail législatif c'est de la co
construction et pas uniquement delà de
la démolition
même quand vient quand bien même c'est
parfois très nécessaire donc c'est pas
du tout un texte qui nous satisfait sur
le fond c'est pas un grand texte
il ya des choses qui manquent énormément
il ya des inquiétudes qui subsistent
il ya quand même des choses l'obsession
du transfert on a vu que c'était quelque
chose et je crois qu'on l'a montré dans
le dernier vote y compris sur le
l'article 65 le transfert à sa juste
place
il faut pas trop en faire sur le
transfert la discussion sur le brevet a
montré qu'il faut être attentif aussi au
fait que l'université publique c'est le
bien commun et donc c'est le partage des
richesses vers l'entreprise mais aussi
vers la société civile et donc si vous
voulez nous avons la liste des regrets
est extrêmement longue
nous veillerons à signaler les modestes
avancées qu'il y a eu et nous aurons la
position on va dire qui va être à
expliciter avec pédagogique est une
position de montrer que le travail
législatif a un sens que le sénat a un
sens et qu'il faut qu'il y ait si ce
texte va en cmp une copie a présenté
face aux textes que nous trouvions
extrêmement mauvais de l'assemblée
nationale donc en train texte
extrêmement mauvais et un texte pas bon
il faut faire oeuvre de pragmatisme et
donc on veut que ce texte puisse vivre
en cmp et après de toute façon la cmp
pourra
pourra trancher donc avec toutes ses
réserves
c'est parce qu'on voulait c'est c'est
parce qu'on attendait mais on va porter
ce texte jusqu'à la cmp est donc nous le
voterons merci mais la mouche ou la
parole et que la madame prima il madame
la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues en début d'examen de ce texte
vous avez exprimé madame la ministre
votre étonnement parce que notre groupe
reprocher à ce projet de loi de ne pas
être un véritable acte deux de
l'autonomie et dans un même temps ils
dénonçaient le fait que l'université
risque de ne voir son élan brisé
effectivement et même après trois jours
de débats motivé de part et d'autre de
débats cordiaux je dois le dire
nous estimons et attentif nous estimons
que ce texte ne porte pas une réforme
majeure la réforme majeure de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche a eu lieu il y a cinq ans avec
la loi lru votre texte ne revient
d'ailleurs pas sur l'acquisition de
l'autonomie que vous avez maintes fois
appelez de vos voeux à blanc appelant
même parfois davantage d'autonomie
il donne ce texte à un accord tacite sur
un grand nombre de mesures que nous
avons mises en place même si bien
évidemment vous avez des réserves
ce texte d'orientation énonce des
principes expriment des intentions mais
n'évoque pas les moyens qu'il consacrera
à ses objectifs nous l'avons dit
d'autres groupes politique l'ont dit sur
ces bancs pas de loi de programmation
mais surtout pas d'engagements chiffrés
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
ont besoin d'investissements besoin de
visibilité
vous avez reconnu d'ailleurs madame la
ministre que l'attribution des moyens et
une décision qui ne vous appartient pas
en effet et nous regrettons avec vous
alors que vous n'ayez pas été entendus
lors des arbitrages en plus de ne pas
être une grande loi je confirme qu en
l'état elle fera perdre du temps à
l'université le projet de loi s'attaque
à plusieurs sujets qui sont déterminants
pour le bon fonctionnement et le succès
de notre enseignement supérieur et de
notre recherche
tout d'abord la gouvernance bicéphale
des univers
cité avec la création d'un pléthorique
conseil académique aux côtés du conseil
d'administration ayant également un
pouvoir décisionnaire qui nous semble
être une disposition à compréhensible
elle crée un véritable risque de blocage
nous l'avons plusieurs fois dit au cours
du débat au sein de nos universités et
cela au moment même où celle ci est
notamment celles d'entre elles qui
rencontrent des difficultés dans
l'acquisition de l'autonomie ont besoin
d'un pilotage fort la loi lru avait
simplifié resserrer la composition du
conseil d'administration pour faciliter
les prises de position vous revenez
ainsi sur un acquis qui nous semblent
essentielles second point la suppression
de la rs nous n'avons toujours pas été
convaincus par vos arguments vous voulez
remplacer cette autorité qui fonctionne
désormais qui est reconnu par nos
partenaires européens et internationaux
proposant un dispositif des vagues
d'évaluation efficaces la rs a seulement
besoin de quelques améliorations pour
satisfaire aussi bien les organismes
évalué que les exigences de qualité de
notre enseignement supérieur et de notre
recherche troisième point les iut
nous continuons à nous opposer à la
fragilisation de ces instituts qui ne
sont pas nos chouchous madame la
ministre comme vous le disiez mais qui
sont des établissements d'excellence
il conjugue plusieurs qualités proches
du monde de l'entreprise
il propose un encadrement des élèves
leur permettant de mieux progresser les
méthodes de travail des iut sont
certainement des recettes à reproduire
dans la première année d'université
dernier point je terminerai par celui ci
car il est essentiel à nos yeux il a été
déterminant dans d'autres dans le choix
de notre vote
vous supprimez les presses et les réseau
thématique de recherche avancée qui sont
elles aussi des structures d'excellence
né de l'alliance de nos meilleurs
établissements à ces structures ou
substituer des communautés dont le mode
de fonctionnement diffère de celui de
celui qui existe aujourd'hui
nous pensons que leur mode
d'organisation complexe risque de nuire
à leur bon fonctionnement et que le
passage des presses à ces communautés
risquent une fois de plus de faire
perdre du temps à nos universités notre
détermination à maintenir l'existence
des presses bien aidé il faut le dire
par la faible mobilisation en début
d'après-midi devant
majorité ont conduit à la suppression de
l'article 38
mais vous avez demandé une seconde
délibération pour effacer ce vote
fâcheux de notre haute assemblée certes
vous avez introduit à cette occasion en
seconde délibération des modifications
importantes auxquelles nous sommes
favorables mais nous pensons que nous
sommes encore loin du compte
néanmoins un de nos amendements que nous
avions déposé en même temps que lui dei
a été adopté il représente un réel
progrès en permettant de clarifier
notamment le statut des établissements
privés d'enseignement supérieur et de
recherche
si toutefois cette disposition parvient
à franchir l'étape de la commission
mixte paritaire ce que évidemment nous
souhaitons malgré quelques amendements
que vous avez bien voulu adopter et des
engagements pris notamment je pense sur
la vie étudiante
nous n'avons pu rétablir une gouvernance
forte des universités ni maintenir de la
rs ni les presse ni aider les ut nous ne
pouvons donc validé ce texte conservant
des dispositions susceptibles de freiner
gravement les universités dans le
développement de leur autonomie
je m'associe avant de terminer aurait
merci mans qui ont été émis au nom de
notre groupe est adressée à madame la
présidente ainsi qu'à l'ensemble des
équipes du sénat qui ont permis ce débat
et avoue même madame la ministre qui
avait permis ce débat apaisé serein et
attentif
même si nous avons et nous conservons
des points de désaccord je m'associe
également à ma collègue bouchons pour
madame bouche ou pour les regrets sur la
procédure accélérée nous voyons que dans
cet hémicycle tous les groupes ont
participé fortement l'évolution de ce
texte les allers-retours les navettes
sont des éléments importants dans
l'évolution d'un texte je regrette
également donc la procédure accélérée
pour toutes ces raisons et regrett mans
vivement que nos arguments n'ai pas
essayé était plus entendu nous voterons
contre ce projet de loi
merci chers collègues la parole est à
david assouline
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission
madame la rapporteure de la commission
les chers collègues nous arrivons à
l'issue d'un débat sur une loi
d'envergure qui a été néanmoins ici
enrichi par des apports sur tous ses
aspects et le la part de tous les
participants
je me réjouis que bientôt des
coopérations et interactions effective
entre le monde universitaire et celui de
la recherche devienne réalité grâce à
des dispositions de rapprochement des
structures mais aussi d' améliorations
d'ordre pédagogique de la même manière
les nombreuses dispositions en faveur de
la réussite des étudiants devraient
permettre à ceux-ci de choisir leur
filière orientations et voie
professionnelle dans de meilleures
conditions
car mieux informer mieux formés mieux
conseiller et bénéficiant de davantage
de conseils de la part des structures en
charge de leur formation
cette loi va enfin permettre d'aborder
dans de nouvelles conditions
rationaliser et démocratiser un nouvel
âge de l'autonomie des établissements
chargés d'un nouveau contenu est porteur
d'une nouvelle dynamique
je me réjouis que le dispositif qui nous
a été soumis est été enrichi par les
apports du sénat ceux votés en
commission puis ceux adoptés en séance
un titre personnel et au nom du groupe
socialiste
je me félicite que presque tous les
amendements que nous avons proposées
durant les deux étapes de la procédure
ait été adopté plus précisément je suis
heureux qu'ils aient été adoptées ou
préciser les points suivants à
l'initiative des sénateurs socialistes
l'inclusion des partenaires de la
société civile associations fondations
d'utilité publique ong comme
destinataire du transfert de la
recherche à de très nombreux articles
dans les codes de l'éducation et de la
recherche cette exigence sera désormais
inscrits
ces ajouts nous étions nombreux dans
cette assemblée à les réclamer et à les
appeler de nos voeux
l'indication que les regroupements
d'établissements et d'organismes seront
resteront facultatif et se feront avec
une grande souplesse figure désormais au
terme de la loi à l'article 38 dans une
version qui je pense est de nature à
satisfaire le plus grand nombre d'entre
nous dans cet hémicycle deux
dispositions particulièrement
importantes concernant les stages
étudiants étaient introduites grâce au
groupe socialiste le droit pour tout
étudiant a effectué un stage pendant les
vacances universitaires est une avancée
très positive
les établissements seront désormais
tenus de donner une convention à tous
jeunes souhaitant effectuer un stage en
rapport avec sa formation de deux mois
la garantie est posée pour qu'au cours
d'une même année universitaire seuls les
stages s'appliquant à des formations à
des métiers dans la durée de 6 mois est
insuffisant puisse dépasser cette durée
la plupart
je suis également très attaché à lui à
l'ajout d'une nouvelle compétence au
bureau d aide à l'insertion
professionnelle des étudiants à qui sera
désormais là comme la mission confiée la
mission de préparer les étudiants à leur
entretien d'embauché
je rappelle que cette création est le
produit d'un amendement dans la loi lru
des sénateurs socialistes
la nouvelle mission d'éducation à la
santé des étudiants du crous constitue
aussi un point positif les conventions
patiente les formations d'enseignement
supérieur des lycées les universités
prévoyant des enseignements communs
permettront de faciliter les passerelles
pour les étudiants entre ces deux types
de formation nous avons aussi obtenu le
maintien de la carte de séjour mention
scientifiques chercheurs
involontairement privé d'emploi jusqu'à
expiration de ses droits au chômage
ouvert par ses cotisations cette mesure
est à la fois emblématique mais aussi de
nature à renforcer l'attractivité de
l'université de la recherche dans notre
pays
la mise en oeuvre du dispositif
permettant de favoriser la coproduction
des schémas régionaux de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et de
l'innovation avec les autres niveaux de
collectivités territoriales et d'en
assurer ainsi la portée prescriptive
permettra enfin aux régions et à toutes
les collectivités d'être associé à la
politique d'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche
la plupart dont de nos apports ont fait
l'objet d'un quasi consensus puisqu'ils
ont le plus souvent été voté par une
large partie de cet hémicycle allant de
la gauche jusqu'au centre des
explications de vote que je viens
d'entendre vienne matérialiser ce
rassemblement très large qui s'opère
pour permettre à ce texte de poursuite
de poursuivre son chemin et d'aller en
cmp avec emportant les souhaits du sénat
de nombreux amendements défendus par mes
collègues issus des différents membres
de cette assemblée ont aussi fait
l'objet d'une large approbation et
permet d'enrichir considérablement le
texte je veux remercier bien sûr le
travail de la commission de sa
rapporteure mais surtout comme je le
faisais dès le début de nos travaux
saluer madame la ministre d'avoir
souvent pris la peine de nous aider dans
ce travail associant l'ensemble des
présents à trouver des rédactions pointu
étant ouverte à prendre le temps pour
trouver les bonnes formulation des
dispositions proposées par les uns et
des autres est de parvenir ainsi à
l'accord le plus large possible sur de
nombreux articles
ça a été décisif je ne doute pas que la
cmp nous permettra encore de progresser
sur certains points cela dit dès à
présent je vous indique que les
sénateurs du groupe socialiste tiennent
à apporter un soutien entier à ce texte
ambitieux pour l'avenir de la recherche
l'information des étudiants
nous voterons pour le projet de loi issu
de nos travaux et le porteront fièrement
dans toutes ses dimensions à la cmp
merci monsieur assouline
y at il d'autres demandes d'explications
de vote
je n'en vois pas je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi relatif à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche
à cet effet j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert nos chers
collègues
mes chers collègues plus personne ne
demande à voter le scrutin et donc logé
invite les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement
et
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 181 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi relatif à
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
nombre de votants 348 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 329 pour l'adoption
172 contre 157 le sénat a adopté
l'ensemble du projet de loi
peut-être mal à blandain vous aviez
demandé la parole très rapidement chers
collègues le sénat 20 voiliers en cmp un
texte il est porteur de la diversité et
je dis bien la diversité de nos
réflexions et il est porteur aussi des
concessions de la ministre que je
remercie pour son écoute car chacun avec
son expertise croit détenir la vérité
et pourtant la vérité neigé personnel et
dans l'ensemble et le croisement de nos
idées le suspense je peux vous le dire
madame la ministre vous l'avez suivi en
partie a été durable aurions-nous un
texte en commission
peu de gens auraient parié y aura-t-il
une question préalable voté par la
conjonction de refus ceux qui veulent
plus de ces hier ceux qui veulent moins
de seiller et au milieu ceux qui
trouvent que le seuil rc bien et les
autres qui trouve que c'est pas bien
y aurait-il une suite d'un amendement de
suppression d'articles nous envoyant
vers l'assemblée un texte complètement
gruyère et défiguré et puis nous avons
eu
hier et ce matin des rangs clairsemés
mais vraiment très clairsemé au point
qu'on pouvait se demander si la parole
de la majorité existerait alors il faut
accuser personne mais quand même
l'inscription par la conférence des
présidents de notre texte avec un jour
de retard
sans doute parce que beaucoup parier sur
le fait qu'il n'y aurait pas de débats
ne nous a pas aidé car un jour de retard
le mardi en moins c'était de longues
soirées en plus c'était le vendredi
n'habite ul c'était la fête de la
musique et nos collègues ne sont pas
partis s'amuser mais beaucoup d'entre
eux ont des responsabilités locales et
ils accueillaient telle ou telle
manifestation et beaucoup d'entre nous
ici ont dû en faire le deuil
et il faut le dire c'est pas très
agréable j'ai une pensée aussi pour nos
collègues du rdse dont les rangs étaient
particulièrement clairsemé mais si vous
regardez leur implantation géographique
ils sont dans l'eau ils sont en train de
s'occuper de leur commune et de leur
territoire et on peut aussi avoir une
pensée pour eux les débats ont été
parfois sur le fil et pourtant il était
très riche très riche qu'on ne peut qu
ensemble retraités quand même
l'urgence car ce que nous avons arraché
parfois dans la douleur ou dans des
interruptions
on aurait pu le faire dans une navette
alors madame la ministre vous avez une
énorme responsabilité pour cette loi
nous avons entendu toutes les demandes
de terrain y compris des demandes
contradictoires mais des demandes tout
fort énergique l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche c'est l'avenir
alors nous ne formerons pas un bon
avenir en adaptant nos vieilles recettes
pour trouver des solutions aux mutations
sociétales économiques et
environnementales donc on a besoin
vraiment d'une recherche innovante
partager avec la société avec un monde
économique capable d'entendre ce qu'il
recherche finalisée du tiw que la cmp
madame lamy
nice ne détricote pas mettez deux bonnes
secondes sur cette cmp tous les acquis
dans leur diversité qui ont été ici
votez et puis toute façon bas si elle
réussit je rappelle à chacun que ces
textes reviennent qu'ils sont soumis aux
votes alors d'habitude c'est une
banalité le vote des conclusions et bien
là ça sera le verdict de respect de ce
que nous avons porté
je remercie bien sûr tous les présents
nos administrateurs si vous savez comme
il nous corrige la moindre faute de
grammaire avec le souci de l'image du
sénat car il n'est pas question
d'envoyer quelque chose qui soit de
mauvaise qualité
et comme ils savent tous des codes de
nos redondance de nous doublons pour
nous éviter des erreurs
je remercie bien sûr au premier chef la
rapporteur qui a bien mouiller la
chemise et qui a vécu tous les aléas et
les incertitudes que je vous évoquez et
bien sûr nous allons changer le
règlement du sénat pour que les
commissions pu choisir leur vice
présidente préféré parce qu'elle nous a
réussi la loire fondation de l'école
elle nous a réussi la loi esr est
vraiment avec un sourire et à rythme
soutenu
elle arrive toujours à faire des débats
riches si madame la présidente
écoutez j'associe à ces remerciements
les services de la séance et du compte
rendu
merci infiniment mesdames le rapporteur
oui madame la présidente madame madame
la ministre mes chers collègues nous
sommes arrivés au bout de ce que les
observateurs nous promettait comme une
épreuve difficile voire insurmontable
je ne reviendrai pas sur la description
que vient d'en faire notre présidente
marie blandin mais c'est vrai que nous
avons vécu un suspense assez assez fort
mais c'est aussi ça la joie du travail
parlementaire
alors nous avons adopté de manière tout
de même assez large
un texte essentiel je vous le disais
mercredi je vous encourageais à rentrer
dans ce texte très vaste très important
certes technique puisque à travers cette
soixante dix articles enrichit encore
d'articles additionnels qui ont été
acceptées par notre assemblée
plus de 600 amendements peut-être 700
amendements étudiés
cet texte traite de sujets complexes
emblématique des enjeux poursuivi la
parité le transfert vers la société le
monde économique la société civile la
formation tout au long de la vie la
gouvernance des universités et de leur
regroupement
l'attractivité du territoire la réforme
de l'évaluation le renfort de
l'autonomie enfin l'accompagnement de la
sécurité sous cet après midi on a traité
de la santé des étudiants disait qu'il y
avait encore un chantier à ouvrir donc
ce texte
à travers ce projet de loi c'est notre
avenir qui est en jeu avec la
refondation de l'école il dessine un
projet global de société
saisissant par sa force et sa cohérence
parce que l'université est un levier
indispensable du redressement de la
france
ce texte nous que nous avons adopté ce
soir cette nuit répond à une exigence
démocratique
une nécessité sociétale de l'évolution
et du partage de la connaissance qui
font la force d'une grande nation et je
crois qu'on a participé tous ensemble à
un acte législatif de grandes de grandes
qualités collectives et
nous avons fait preuve d'une extrême
responsabilité enrichissant et
l'enrichissement et l'approbation d'une
loi majeure pour l'avenir de notre
société qui concrétise une des priorités
du président de la république à savoir
celle pour la jeunesse pour l'avenir de
notre société c'est aussi un acte qui
marque l'honneur de notre assemblée
l'honneur du sénat ça a été dit par
plusieurs d'entre vous avoir su
travailler un texte transmis de
l'assemblée nationale dans un contexte
de doutes sur son aboutissement compte
tenu des votes exprimés au palais
bourbon
ce texte nous était arrivé comme un
produit fini qui n'auraient justifiait
qui n'aurait pas permis devant les
équilibres politiques en présence dans
notre assemblée la discussion
approfondie voire même la simple
discussion
or après presque huit heures de travail
en commission plus de 26 heures de débat
public
notre capacité à faire à produit cette
conclusion qui est une belle
démonstration de ce que le débat
politique sincère respectueux
constructif peut apporter réguler pardon
concrètement à l'activité législative
peut-être même que c'est l'étroitesse de
nos équilibres qui nous ont valu qui
nous a valu quelques émotions d'ailleurs
ces dernières heures
cette étroitesse qui a rendu nos débats
et notre écoute dans le respect des uns
et des autres sans polémiques inutiles
je vous remercie tous d'avoir su éviter
ces polémiques inutiles qui peuvent
démarrer d'un seul coup comme un coup de
grisou et qui entravent définitivement
le débat et nous avons su éviter ces
polémiques inutiles et à mon tour je
voudrais remercier notre présidente qui
a su nous nous guider avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de douceur je pourrais dire
mais aussi de fermeté et de savoir faire
pour que nos débats restent fructueux et
le plus souvent serein alors je suis
très heureuse je pense que nous pouvons
être fiers collectivement et je remercie
chacun d'entre vous
malheureusement pour ce bon climat de
discussion ces heures de débats si elles
n'ont pas totalement convaincu j'ai bien
entendu les les explications qui ont été
données elles ont tout de même permis
d'apporter des précisions de rassurer
d'ouvrir des pistes de compréhension et
de rassemblement qu'il nous faudra
préserver et faire grandir
alors c'est un moment extrêmement
positif pour vous madame la ministre qui
vous êtes investi si fort dans la
défense de ce projet au service de la
nation et je veux remercier moi aussi
notamment tous ceux de nos
collaborateurs dans cette belle maison
qui nous ont permis de faire ce travail
fructueux qui nous ont facilité le
travail
et comme le disait madame blandin grâce
à une excellente technicité nous
apprennent tous les jours un peu plus le
maniement des codes et nous permettent
d'y trouver du plaisir et puis je
voudrais avoir un dernier clin d'oeil en
sachant que j'aurai forcément oublier
quelques quelques personnes j'allais
oublier les membres du cabinet qui ont
beaucoup donné aussi et qui ont su
travailler avec nos collaborateurs pour
que le travail soit bien préparé que les
difficultés soient aplanies mais je
voudrais un dernier dans un dernier clin
d'oeil dire que ça a été un beau moment
de mobilisation intense même si les
présences et terreur des vraies forces
vives dans notre assemblée dans laquelle
les femmes ont été particulièrement
présente madame la rapporteure messieurs
alfonsi vous vouliez dire un mot avant
madame la présidente il n'est pas
d'usagé de m'exprimer
la fin d'un débat après les mots du
rapporteur et damien ministre mais je ne
fais pas preuve d'une grande assiduité
dans cet hémicycle au demeurant tout le
monde a dû s'en apercevoir
mais ce sont des choses qui n'est
peut-être pas nécessaire de dire et
j'ajoute que je ne tiens pas une
comptabilité notariale des gens qui sont
présents
dans cet hémicycle dans tous les groupes
et quand madame blandin à observer avec
une attention et une vigilance
particulière l'absence des membres du
groupe de r d assaut imputant sans doute
leur absence à des dégâts dans nine west
pensant que ce soit du seul motif tout
le monde s'en étaient aperçus il n'y a
pas que la représentation du sud ouest
et tous les membres du mdc ne sont pas
dans le sud-ouest ce soir ils peuvent
être absent pour d'autres motifs
tous les autres groupes s'en était
aperçu j'aurais souhaité que vous même
fusé dans cette situation si monsieur
alfonsi la parole et à madame la
ministre
pour conclure je ne voudrais pas trop
prolonger ce débat sinon on va croire ça
s'est tellement bien passé qu'on
n'arrive pas à se quitter finalement
mais on se on sort on se retrouvera donc
merci à tous à mon tour je voudrais
remercier la présidente cher marisa
décidément ça va devenir un peu le
trèfle à quatre feuilles de cette haute
assemblée donc il va falloir aussi
l'aménager parce que il faut que les
autres présidents également soin soit
sollicité mais la douceur cache parfois
de la fermeté et j'ai trouvé que vous
possédiez très bien très bien et
maîtrisez très bien ces deux qualités
merci aussi à dominique gillot moi je
veux dire ce qui m'a frappé c'est que
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
certes ça donne une grande
responsabilité parce qu'effectivement on
préfigure l'avenir mais ça donne aussi
de grands bonheurs
quand on va dans un laboratoire quand on
va dans un amphithéâtre et qu'on
rencontre les étudiants ont des
ressources et d'une façon absolument
formidable je trouve que c'est une
délégation qui contraint à la générosité
et à la projection dans l'avenir
ils servent un pardon et ça permet
ensemble de se projeter finalement de se
tirer ensemble vers le haut et j'ai
trouvé pendant ces débats au cours de
ces trois journées
on n'est pas d'accord sur tout ça me
paraît normal on ne convergent pas sur
tout non plus parfois cher corps et de
moins par mois ça finit par faire plus
c'est woody allen qui le dit avant moi
mais malgré tous ensemble on peut avoir
des échanges d'une dune de grande
qualité et je trouve que finalement on y
met toute la passion ce sont des sujets
qui passionnent et on a eu un débat qui
n'a pas été un débat technique moi j'ai
trouvé qu'on avait échappé un débat
technique sur tel ou tel article on a eu
un débat qui est discutée vraiment
problème comme les distraits bien
dominique nos problèmes de fond parce
que finalement travers l'université la
recherche on touche à tout
tous les to les questions qu'est la
société est confrontée toutes les
questions aussi qui parfois peuvent
susciter des craintes des appréhensions
on touche au contexte économique dans
lequel nous vivons et on sait que nous
savons que les étudiants aujourd'hui
vivent dans des conditions parfois
difficiles et que cela affecte aussi
leurs résultats
donc ça nous donne certes des
responsabilités mais ministre travaille
avec un gouvernement qu'un président de
la république et travaille avec deux
assemblées donc nous sommes tous
collectivement responsables et je crois
que c'est ça qui nous a rendu aussi
aussi responsable et j'allais dire aussi
contributeurs d'un débat indigne anges à
dire que l'atmosphère ici j'irai pas
qu'elle est feutrée mais malgré tout
elle pousse à la sérénité peut-être
davantage que dans une assemblée que
j'ai bien connu pendant cinq ans qu'est
l'assemblée nationale et c'est vrai que
les administrateurs mais aussi
l'ensemble du personnel de la séance y
contribue grandement et je les en
remercie parce qu'on travaille mieux
dans la sérénité sans stress et sans
aucune invective
encore une fois je ne vous fais pas un
discours bisounours
je crois que nous étions là aussi pour
confronter nos points de vue mais je me
réjouis vraiment du fond du coeur des
convergences que nous avons pu trouver
les plus rien n'est fini les grands
soirs je crois que ça n'existe plus il
n'y a que des soirs où on essaye de
dégager des perspectives n'avançais pas
a pas d'avancée j'allais dire en eau des
tomes en honnêtes femmes
beaucoup de femmes ça peut-être
contribué aussi à la réussite de ce
débat
personne n'avait vraiment préconisé
enfin on m'avait dit attention sénat en
ce moment c'est difficile c'est tendu tu
vas voir tu vas te faire dépecer ce
projet de loi j'ai trouvé non j'ai
trouvé que non qu'il avait été au
contraire enrichi je voulais tous de
tout corps vous aurez mercier et surtout
vous remercier d'avoir compris les deux
priorités qui sont celles du
gouvernement est que ce projet de loi
incarne et oui qu'il incarne avec
ambition sans grands soirs on peut quand
même avoir de l'ambition et ses deux
priorités c'est la réussite
la réussite des étudiants une priorité
essentielle sans laquelle notre avenir
ne sera pas le même et la seconde
ambition c'est une ambition partagée je
crois que c'est important même s'il a
dit partager pour pour la recherche
alors tout n'est pas fini valérie la l'a
bien dit nous allons travailler encore
ray cmp nous allons travailler encore à
l'assemblée nationale et surtout nous
allons travailler ensemble et je compte
sur vous je compte sur l'office
parlementaire je compte sur chacun des
parlementaires pour m'aider à avancer
pour les faits moi que je passerai comme
ministre mais surtout pour faire avancer
le projet parce qu'au-delà des personnes
c'est bien tout l'avenir de notre pays
qui se joue merci à vous toutes et à
vous tous et très bonne fin de fête de
la musique quand même marie-christine
merci merci madame la ministre nous
quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette séance je vous
rappelle donc que le projet de loi
portant réforme de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche a été
adopté dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
par à les sénateurs bonne fin de journée
à tous